I started this alone and I had every
intention of keeping it that way
how to plan life had a different one
and then things just got stranger
partners artists but the hard
inescapable truth is that sometimes
we're not enough sometimes the world
needs a team you call this a team
a girl with wings in the past lives
complex a deceased assassin
a pair of criminals
and a billionaire was more tech than he
clearly knows what to do with I know
exactly what to do with it most of the
time and I'm a half a hero and my other
half is combustible
what you're up against is bigger than
all of us which is why it's gonna take
all of you
his name is Vandal Savage he's been
alive thousands of years he is immortal
and commands the most powerful army the
world has ever seen and what makes you
think we could stop him because one day
you do rip hunter I'm from East London
oh and the future I'm a member of the
time masters an organization charged
with detecting history itself and in the
future as unlikely as it may seem you
people become a team
well those of you who survive at Beast
savages evil spans the course of history
so we will have to travel through time
to stop him
that's where savage can throw to us we
got this thing nailed down why did you
say that
I can't imagine any kind of future where
I am a hero well you know in the future
none of you are heroes
you're legends
so you weren't dead nope
you were just small you don't believe me
all right just watch
hey youtubers is Charlie so they posted
the legends trailer early the one that
we're going to air after the flash
there's going to be a breakdown of that
so biggest news first
Caity Lotz is confirmed as the white
canary she's going to be resurrected in
the Lazarus Pit rip hunters a time
travel so that's probably how they're
going to get her there fast enough
normally the Lazarus Pit only works for
a certain period of time after death
Caity Lotz did say in an interview that
her personality would be a little bit
different the producers said that the
Lazarus Pit would have some after
effects on Thea's character so Sierra's
character is just going to be the same
thing but the other big thing to see you
know speaking of after-effects
this will crossover with flash and arrow
the voiceover footage from Oliver's
taken from arrow season 3 but berry
actually appears with the cast fighting
in the legends of tomorrow show rip
hunter actually says that they have to
travel through time to fight the big bad
which is now confirmed to be Vandal
Savage I'm so happy about that
he's one of my big favorite villain
characters that DC just hasn't done on
TV yet there's a lot of questions about
firestorm on the spin-off series because
Victor Garber is part of it
but Robbie Amell wasn't named to the
cast so it sounds like firestorm still
requires two people the show is actually
going to air whenever arrow in the flash
comeback during the mid-season premiere
that'll be January sometime like the end
of January so this will probably air on
like Thursdays but they haven't
announced a premiere date what's going
to happen is is Supergirl is going to be
on Mondays at a p.m. with the probably
do with this is put it on Thursdays just
so it doesn't have to compete a lot of
what Oliver said in the trailer is from
the end of that arrow finale where he
talked about you know I started doing
this alone and eventually I realized I
couldn't do it without a team the
difference with the spin-off team is
that they're trying to save the world
not just one city so it'll feel like a
much more international show they're
making it to be like a 13 hour movie
like a Netflix series almost it will be
13 one-hour episodes though but it'll be
highly serialized we do get a pretty
good shot of Hawkgirl flying around but
we don't actually get like a really good
close-up of her with her costume on I'm
interested to see a little bit more from
Arthur Darvill rip hunter we've seen
time travel on the flash but this is
taking it to a whole new level we do get
to see the atom shrink down for the
first time I know some of you guys had a
lot of questions in my arrow finale
video about what happened to Ray Palmer
that was ever just him like getting
embedded with
the nanotech so now he can shrink down
that's why they said in the trailer so
you weren't dead no I was just shrunk
down that kind of makes it sound like
team arrows gonna think that he's dead
whenever season four picks up as you can
see this takes place at STAR Labs so you
know just more flash crossover this
might be the same clip that they're
gonna play after the flash finale or it
might be something that's a little more
linear like them actually meeting for
the first time like rip hunter showing
up either way let me know what you guys
are most excited about in this trailer
Arthur Darvill time traveling again you
know the atom shrinking Vandal Savage
really Vandal Savage is the exciting
part I think I'll totally include
questions from this in my Q&A video
tomorrow for air on the flash so do be
sure to watch the flash finale next week
because the footage they show might be
different in case you guys haven't seen
it you can click here to watch my arrow
season finale video and you can click
here to watch the Supergirl footage
there's six minutes from the pilot if
you haven't seen it thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you